today I learned that when it snows in
New York manhole covers go missing
summertime means long city bike rides
dead trees and rats and well something
happens with dogs in July I'm Ronen Maya
Google developer advocate join me as I
use the core function 30 gigabytes of
weather records and 130 geeks of New
York City public data to investigate
correlations if not causations with
weather in New York City with bigquery
trapped in the unchanging timeless
stasis of this top-secret and totally
real Google Data Center I don't get much
in the way of weather but that doesn't
mean I can't use bigquery to see how the
weather effects the lucky people who get
to experience how to live for example as
the temperature rises into the 70s
people take more city bike trips and
more of those rides start from the outer
boroughs that's not really surprising
where it gets interesting is the
unexpected correlations like snow and
missing manhole covers to find more
weather correlations we need to dig
through 200 gigabytes of data B query is
fast and cheap but it'll be faster and
cheaper if we make our data a bit more
manageable the NOAA global summary of
daily tables include a dozen weather
variables recorded from 9000 stations
dating back to 1929
and we don't need all of that we'll
extract just the weather variables we
need and replace the triple 9.99 values
which are used to represent null with
zero so that our averages make a little
bit more sense
airports tend to provide the best
weather data and in New York
that means LaGuardia and JFK so we'll
select just those and average their
daily records the normal tables are
split by year so let's combine
everything from 2009 to 2016 the date
range for our New York data sets saving
the results to its own table results in
a very manageable 200 kilobytes now
using our weather table let's see if
temperatures have any effect on cab
rides
unlike the city bikes in this graph
doesn't show a strong pattern but what
other interesting patterns can we find
we all know that correlation doesn't
imply causation but maybe if we're just
looking for interesting patterns
we can use correlations as a way of
finding them calculating correlation is
a pain in that it's hard and graphing
every possibility would take forever but
thankfully B query includes the core
function to do all the hard work for us
this query returns the correlations
between each of our weather variables
and each of the primary causes of the
motor vehicle accidents the results
table suggests two possibility accidents
caused by slippery pavements related to
snow and wind gusts related to runaway
cars graphing both against time there's
some evidence that slipping accidents
increases when there's heavy snow what
about gusty winds pushing runaway cars
down the streets of New York I like it
to be true but does the data support it
well let's say for now it's too early to
tell we've only got data for runaway
cars for the last four months and when
we graph it there's just not enough
there so where to next we query includes
every municipal complaint made to 3 1 1
so there's dozens of different complaint
types that we can try and link to
weather patterns using the core function
I ran queries to find the top
correlations for temperature snow depth
wind speed wind gusts and rain the most
likely candidates temperature
relationships with heating complaints
dead trees and rat sightings snow depth
relationships with missing manhole
covers in illegal parking and higher
wind speeds with lower noise complaints
you can find a link to the full table
and the queries here now it's no
surprise that the call volume for
heating complaints is significantly
higher when the temperature is lower
what is surprising was a similar
correlation between missing manhole
covers and snow depth so either the
abominable snowman is in New York with
penchant for manhole covers or if we
have our causation reversed manhole
covers are what's preventing New York
from being swallowed by a snowpocalypse
now whether it's a snowman or a
snowpocalypse when graphed over time
there is a fairly consistent pattern of
heavy snow and reports for missing
manhole covers the amount of snow
doesn't seem that significant
maybe the holes in the road are more
noticeable when the rest of the street
is white snow depth and illegal parking
turns out to be a dead end
blocked hydrant complaints are trending
up as is snowfall and while double
parking had some coincident spikes with
heavy snow in 2010 and 2016 there wasn't
really much else there either way New
Yorkers may be stopped parking in front
of fire hydrants knuckle you notice that
there were a lot of strong correlations
with temperature such as complaints
about trees and the clearest thing in
this graph is that there's a seasonal
pattern affecting both which is made
even clearer when you look at the
monthly averages so let's take those
monthly averages and seasonally adjusted
results to see if there's a pattern
beyond the time of year this graph
measures the proportion of the months
tree related calls to temperature minus
the monthly average and there's really
not much to speak of in terms of trend
now wind speed had a strong correlation
with noise complaints we know New York
City has windier weather in the winter
so let's just
seasonally adjust for that right away if
we graph all our points as a scatter
plot you can almost see a relationship
but there's also a lot of noise here
we've put our results into buckets of
one degree averaging the volumes for
each bucket and the relationship is much
clearer but it's also a little bit
deceptive it totally hides the variance
and gives undue weight to the buckets
the extremes that represent far fewer
samples which is why we have the magic
of the hex bin graph here we can graph
all the points within a given hex and
weight the darkness of each hex by the
number of points it contains as a result
we can see a trend from the overall
shape of the distribution as well as a
heat map of measurement distribution for
wind and noise you can see a triangular
pattern that implies a weak negative
correlation suggests a greater
likelihood of getting more noise
complaints when the wind is low and
significantly fewer calls when the wind
is five knots above the monthly average
particularly fill-out talking which
almost gives us a ban in a diagonal line
for both the overall distribution and
the area of highest concentration
neither approach explains barking dogs
though it's troubling
why do barking dog complaints go down in
summer what happens to the dogs are they
on vacation do they share a house in the
Hamptons are they locked outside are
they locked inside why are they silent
I think we've stumbled on something here
something big we've got to get the
message out there's no telling
check out the link below to find the
largest subset of possible weather
complaints correlations and please dig
in to find other nuggets hidden within
the data as always with bigquery your
first terabyte of processing each month
is free go to bigquery today and create
your own New York City visualizations
and share them with us using the today I
learned with bigquery hashtag and don't
forget to check out some of our other
today I learned videos and the playlist
and of course subscribe to our channel
and follow our blog to learn something
new with bigquery